the thing that he's really proud that he
can do is that he can both beat box and
bike at the same time
i guess has something to do with him
living in the netherlands and probably
you know they train you that from birth
how to get on a bike
so everyone please welcome a long-time
member of the meet up your own
hey jared
thank you very much for the introduction
and hello
welcome in the next 20 minutes i'm going
to try to convince you that if you've
written any r code that you should
consider turning it into a command line
tool
and i'm going to start at the beginning
what is the command line
and then why should you care about this
and after that
how can you turn your existing r code
into a command line tool
so first about that title
when i say free i mean there are several
interpretations of the word free so
there's free as in beer there is free as
in speech i'm not going to talk about
those things
i'm also not going to talk about
versioning code and packaging code and
distributing code these are all
important yes and megan
the previous speaker
also talked about this um but for this
talk it's out of scope
i'm going to talk about free as in bird
in a sense that your r code can go
wherever that it can be used by anyone
anywhere even if they're not our users
themselves
so
this is what the command line looks like
i mean on your system it may look
different
it's an interactive environment that's
over 50 years old can you imagine that
50 years
um
so the command line allows you to run
command line tools that can help you
do all sorts of things so and when you
know which spouse to cast uh which
incantations
um
to conjure up
then the command line offers unlimited
uh possibilities
and while it remains a stark and
unforgiving environment for interacting
with uh with data and your computer in
in general
even nature
recently argued that
researchers should embrace the command
line they say it can help wrangle big
files uh parallelize your computations
and automate your work
and yes there are
plenty of other reasons most importantly
oh
yeah i should have shown you this most
importantly it can save you
from velociraptors and yes that is also
a jurassic park reference i feel that i
now after 25 years of that movie coming
out
i should say that
so um plenty of reasons um but i'm not
here to use the command line no i want
you to consider
to turn your code into a command line
tool
so something that can be executed from
the command line
the unix command line is not just on
your laptop it can also be found in
other places such as microcontrollers uh
up to supercomputers and plenty of
programming languages and environments
have the ability to leverage the command
line so here's r and r studio where
um
i have some code the code itself is not
that important now but in this code i
leverage command line tools and um
it wasn't until long ago that uh
our studio the environment uh even got a
terminal tab so that you can type um
commands and entire pipelines
inside the rstudio ide
here is an example of that other
language and jupiter lab we can again
see some code on the left
this is
um
a command line that can be run
this is a command line tool that counts
words i have actually the same example
in a moment in our code just want to
show you a couple of examples where this
can be leveraged and on the right here
there is a
jupiter notebook that also is able to
run the command line so even though this
technology is over 50 years old there
are still plenty of places uh where uh
it still gets uh love
and lastly i am i highlighted this from
the uh book spark the definitive guide
by bill chambers and mathias aharia
and it's i highlighted the pipe method
is probably one of spark's more
interesting methods so that's a method
where you can uh send yeah your data
through
a command line tool and i i think that's
actually quite a a compliment from
the original author of apache spark
so right the command line command line
tools all sorts of
places
um
let's have a look and how you can create
a tool yourself
and all you have to do is follow these
six easy steps
i'm kidding i mean they're
relatively easy once you know about them
um in fact it's it's the code itself
that you produce that's that's the
hardest part
um
so i can imagine that right now you're
feeling a little bit like alice tumbling
down the rabbit hole
uh don't worry let's let's take the red
pill and and see where there where this
is going
i'm going to be showing you an example
in r
um
[Music]
and hopefully that will make it clear
how you can um yeah use that
in your own code
it's a very simple example so that we
can focus on the process itself
and i'm going over this a bit pretty
fast if you're interested in this
chapter 4 of my book which
i uh owe
uh to jared i mean i owe jared a lot
without jared this book wouldn't exist
right i mean that is that is quite a lot
to say but it is true
so
um
chapter four it's also uh available for
free online if you're interested the
second edition is going to come out any
day now
exciting stuff
so here's an example um
the code here that i'm or the tool is
called topwords.r although the command
line doesn't care about extensions and
what this tool does it takes in some
text could be any text and then shows
the most common words in this case
i'm passing in a file alice.txt which is
the book adventures of alice in
wonderland and it returns the top
five words five because we've passed
that here as an argument
and i should also say the command line
really doesn't care in which language a
tool is written so
that could of course also be r
let's have a look at what this code
looks like and i know that this is a lot
of code to digest so let me just
highlight three lines that
make this a command line tool so line
one the first line here
you'll see special character a hash and
an exclamation mark this is actually
called the
hashbang or shebang and this tells the
shell
which executable should be used to
interpret this code and in this case
that is r
or r script
the second line line number two that's
where we got that where we get that five
so with the function command args we um
we can get all the command line
arguments that have been passed by the
users
and then lastly lines 9 and 10 that's
how we read in from
standard input this this input channel
and in this case i've passed in a file
but this could also be coming from a
database or or from a website
doesn't matter
so
and all the other code i mean that's not
the most important thing here
in fact
just to show you i've implemented the
same functionality at this base
functionality also in in bash and in
python and in all cases you get the same
result and the command line again
doesn't care
so can you imagine if you were
if if your code your r code could be
used by someone else who had who never
uses r
but has some knowledge of the command
line right and that really
enables your code to be free
and i also want to give special mention
um to a an r package and a cran package
or our package that's on cran called lil
r
by derek adelbutu
and uh this actually predates the the r
script executable and um
he has a bunch of examples a bunch of
command line tools that he often uses
which are included with this package and
in this particular case it's um
a small script that allows you to
install our packages directly from the
command line so you don't need to start
our
yourself first it's just a small example
but then again
many of these tools are small and when
you have many tools then
then they add up
and they'll make you more efficient
i
took this to an extreme by creating a
tool or an r package called rush
and this allows you to run r expressions
uh directly from the command line
so what we're doing here is i'm i have
some
data set about wine and then i call a
bunch of uh functions from the tidy
verse and then i write the output again
to a csv file here you can see the
yellow text that's actually the r
expression but then this now this tool
takes care of all the boilerplate that
you would normally have to do
just um like i said i'm taking this to
the extreme i mean it can even
produce
simple visualizations
and i guess that what i also wanted to
highlight here is that the command line
arguments that you can pass
to well your tool perhaps
um
can also be defined in a more
user-friendly way
and one way where you can do that is by
using uh a doc opt um what that
basically means is that here you have
this usage right this this this long
list of arguments and their x ex
explanations what doc opt is doing it
takes this um this text and it produces
a a mechanism
for turning
the command line arguments into r
variables that your script can then use
oh yeah and this tool rush it can even
plot in the terminal itself and
it uses a couple of other packages uh
to do that so
uh you don't have to take it to this
extreme this is just another example of
but this is probably as as far as you or
maybe even farther than you really want
to go
still a couple of closing thoughts here
the steps to do this and i realized that
i have skipped over a few um you know
that remember that slide with alice
right there were six steps and you know
what if you're really interested in that
it's probably better if you just read uh
chapter four of my book and it has a
a lot of references to other resources
that you can consult um but like i said
those steps are
relatively easy what's more difficult is
is
thinking about okay how can i turn my r
code which may be
a long analysis or
how can i turn that into a something
that can be reused by others
it's kind of like
writing a function
inside a package that others can use but
now
it's it's something it's a building
block that everybody can potentially use
now when it's a tool one of the benefits
is that it's now able to tap into this
ecosystem of tools because there are
tools to do basically everything
anything
paralyzing things running things at
specific times
running it on a different computer
right that they will all work together
and even when you yourself
don't really use the command line
someone else might
and like i've said at the very beginning
uh topics like packaging and
distribution and documentation these are
all still
could all still part of this similar to
creating a package in r
um
so but that's uh yeah those were some of
the things that i uh couldn't talk about
in this uh short amount of time and with
that
i want to thank you i'm gonna be around
uh during the conference i am in a
different time zone i'm six hours ahead
of you i'm in rotterdam the netherlands
but i'm gonna try to be in a few
breakout rooms in case you have any
questions i'd be happy uh to answer all
of them
again
thank you
very much
and uh enjoy the rest of the conference
thank you very much euron um i always
love the command line talks i have uh
over the years keep using more of the
command line i'll always like send a
little dm to your own hey how can i do
this on the command line and he always
has an answer and it really is a fast
way to do things it really really is
fantastic
so
i would like to bring up to